any experience on the road good or bad
at the end of the day it's gonna be a
story and it's gonna be fun with touring
comes meeting new people crazy
experiences our European bus driver who
scammed us big-time would probably be
one of our craziest big time we get to
the venue in the morning in Stuttgart
Germany it's really small really hot
venues and so we were making jokes about
like I don't want to do it there in the
conversation he's like oh come on you
know you got to go make that money and
play the show you make sure we're back
at Fusco our tour manager knocks on the
door and we're not getting anything we
thought something was wrong this band
were with their guitar player Matt come
to a sudden he's like hey I think our
money's gone
and then our tour manager rich opens a
bag and he's just like nothing no money
someone tells you that fifteen thousand
euros is just gone stolen for me to you
to sit there and like that's a weird
feeling
my name is Jay Co I'm a DJ and producer
I've been asked to have you had like one
I made a moment but like the reality is
I have them all the time
just recently I did my first tour in
Australia and I'm sitting there floating
in the water in Bondi Beach hanging back
to times when I just graduated college I
was in Boston and I would travel to New
York to do six hour DJ set for two to
three hundred bucks where I would have
to take the Chinatown Express which is
the worst bus you could ever be on
anyone who knows knows after my gigs
sometimes I would just literally sleep
at the foot of the Manhattan Bridge for
a couple hours so I could take that bus
back once you hit a goal you got to have
the next goal a story that sticks out
more than the rest would be when we went
to Fresno Oh first now I saw this dog
just wandering in the streets like stop
traffic in rush hour - Robert you look
good holding that dog Thanks he was
toting it around he's like guitar dogs
so we grabbed it and started trying to
talk to people or donkeys John says we
were seeing this dog the lady spotted
you and it like chose you she comes up
to us and she's like that's my dog
that's my dog unless well we're not
trying to steal this dog she walks away
from us and then she just
your pants down in the middle of the
parking lot and just starts peeing in
the middle of the parking lot
with her dog in hand I think it was at
that point we realized there are no
rules and Fresno no rules
you